we are so saddened by the tragic events
in boulder this week
and we're also frustrated because the
majority of americans are in favor of
stricter gun laws
but stricter gun laws will never pass
because of a thing called the filibuster
and that's not the only damage the
filibuster has caused
let's find out why else it's bad in a
segment called how did we get here
a filibuster is an action that a senator
can take
to keep the senate from voting on a bill
there are 100 senators so
if any one of them introduces a bill any
of the other 99 can stop it from getting
voted on
it's basically legislative blocking
i'm sorry is that sexist blocking can we
say
blocking on tv we just did
so senators stop bills from getting
voted on
a lot which is crazy because voting is
their job
it would be like if at any point in the
day one of your co-workers could stand
up on his desk and say
i don't think we should ship office
supplies to the southwest region today
and then
you all had to stop working and watch
him give a speech about it
meanwhile i'm at home refreshing my
tracking information like
where's madame stapler i have papers to
connect
the filibuster is just a long-winded way
to keep things from getting done and
it isn't even in the constitution it was
created in 1806 by aaron burr the bad
guy
from hamilton leslie i love you and you
can get it
and i'm willing to wait for it but
the filibuster didn't start to become
what we know it as now until
1841 when senator john calhoun realized
it could be used to protect minority
rights
which he defined as my right to own
minorities
calhoun wanted to ensure that the
slave-owning minority of senators
would be able to override the majority
of senators who didn't own slaves so
they could protect slavery so on the
surface the filibuster seems fine but
if you look closer it's very racist just
like mel gibson
originally in order to filibuster you
had to stand up and talk the whole time
so
while you could delay a bill all
filibusters eventually ended when the
dude got sleepy or had to pee
or had to go polish his top hat i don't
know what people did back then
the point is at some point the
filibuster used to end but that changed
during the jim crow era now anytime a
story skips from slavery times to jim
crow times you know it's not going
anywhere good
in 1917 rule 22 was introduced rule 22
requires a super majority of senators to
stop a filibuster
sounds good right it even has the word
super in it but
in practice until 1964
the super majority was only used to stop
civil rights legislation
that mean that every other bill could
pass with 51 votes but
civil rights bills effectively needed 67
to get past the inevitable filibuster
isn't that crazy it's like oh no no no
it's a totally neutral thing
it just somehow only ever gets used to
hurt black people
you know like police the record for the
longest one-man filibuster is held by
strom thurmond
who also holds the record for most
racist sounding name
they may as well have named him
segregation oh confederate
in 1957 thurman filibustered the civil
rights act for
24 hours do you know how much you have
to hate someone to stand on your feet
and talk for a whole day i have several
terrible
ex-boyfriends and the longest i can go
on any one of them is 15 minutes
after that i'm too tired to keep caring
even civil rights bills that should pass
easily get caught up by filibusters
there are 200
anti-lynching bills that haven't been
passed by the senate
200 we can get millions of americans to
make their own sourdough bread but we
can't get
60 to vote against lynching
even crazier these days senators don't
even have to show up to work to
filibuster
any senator can send an email and if 60
other senators don't feel like
challenging it
that's enough to filibuster a bill and
the senator doesn't even have to tell
the american people why
and i think they should if you're
getting paid by my tax dollars to
not make lynching illegal i want you to
have to stand up there and say
why and i want you to be wearing really
pointy uncomfortable shoes when you do
it
also i'm sure every speech would start
out with some pretty language about
states rights or something but
there is no way a racist can talk that
long without saying something racist and
i want to see it i think it would be
funny so
now you're thinking okay just because
the filibuster started out racist and
then was only used to be racist for a
long time
that doesn't mean it's racist now right
oh you sweet summer child
it's true that these days the filibuster
is used for a wider variety of issues
but
any guesses on when republicans set the
record for doing the most filibusters
can you guess who was in office i'll
give you one more guess
that's right so the filibuster is like
when you see a white person buying brown
makeup on halloween
technically they could be using it for
anything but they're probably going to
do a racism
so that's how we got to where we are now
thanks in large part to the filibuster
we are still struggling with black
people's voting rights
don't believe me ask representative park
cannon
the georgia lawmaker who got arrested
just for knocking on the door of someone
who was trying to pass a voter
suppression law
she got charged with a felony just
kidding she got charged with two
can you imagine telling someone marching
in the 60s that we
still wouldn't have this stuff figured
out by 2021
they'd be so disappointed then they'd be
like but you guys have flying cars right
and you'd have to be like oh no but we
have automatic sinks
but they don't recognize black people
sorry the future is bad
the filibuster is keeping black
americans from having full voting rights
and
it's keeping all americans from being
safe from gun violence and
frankly the word itself sounds very
stupid
democrats should get rid of it or at
least make senators see how long they
can talk without letting the n-word slip
out this has been how did we get here
you